before you can be a painter who can
paint what's beyond mere memory you have
to inculcate that discipline skill and a
lot of that is painful repetition and
hard grinding work it's the sacrifice of
the present for the future but once you
manage that then things open up and
virtually everything you learn of value
is like that's very very very difficult
to learn to write and there's arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're a rank beginner even to some
degree whatever creativity you have is
going to have to be stifled while you're
passing through that Keyhole but if you
pass through it then something massive
opens up on the other side and it is
definitely the case that disciplinary
institutions universities are exactly
that is there places of guidance and
there are places to encourage people to
develop the discipline that's necessary
to see beyond the discipline I mean
that's why we have disciplines the words
aren't there by accident you have to
narrow yourself first and then you can
broaden outward and that that's part of
the process of maturation that's part of
the sacrifice of childhood in childhood
you're nothing but potential but it's
not realized and you don't know how to
realize it and so then the question is
well how do you get to a point where you
realize the potential and the answer is
you sacrifice almost all of it to a
single Direction This is Nietzsche's
commentary on the Catholic Church he's a
great admirer of the Catholic Church
despite the fact that he was also a
radical critic critic of Christianity
said the cow see the thing about the
Catholic church is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline and once that
discipline was established then the
disciplined mind could explode in every
direction which is precisely what
happened and so and and and that's the
thing about growing up is that when
you're a teenager and a young adult you
have to sacrifice everything you could
have been as a child to be the one thing
that you're aiming at but then that
opens up and and the universities are
part and parcel of that process and you
need the guidance because the the the
library is too large to wander through
it unaided the problem isn't that people
aren't willing to make sacrifices the
problem is that you're not sure if
you're making the right sacrifice or not
you're worried that there might be
another path that you might make the
wrong choice and then you will regret it
that is crippling thinking and today I'm
going to teach you how to escape it
knowing what decision you should make is
actually not that difficult Having the
courage to go off and do it is a
different story because chances are
whatever you want to do will require
courage is going to be outside your
comfort zone is not what you went to
school for it's not what your parents or
your friends want you to do it's
something totally wild and different and
we often come up with really logical
reasons why we can't do it but finding
the path to making the right choice is
not that difficult I'm going to give you
a three-step process that will help
number one is understand that you are
built to serve it's the same it's the
name of my new book built to serve you
can pick it up you can pre-order right
now Evan carmichael.com book go check it
out go get it but you are built to serve
you want to help other people so in
terms of making decisions you want to do
things that will serve other people
serving others is hardwired into us they
did fmri scans of the brain and when you
help other people it hits the same part
of your brain as food and sex more than
receiving more than getting gifts is
helping others serving others being of
use you want to wake up every day and
feel like the work you do matters that
you're having an impact we all want to
go off and have an impact you are built
to serve and so already in your decision
making does it serve somebody else does
it help other people in some way if it's
yes you're making progress in the book I
go through a three-step process who I
how so who your one word most important
core value what do you stand for who are
you you have one word that is more
important than all the others so I
believe is my most important core value
and so already the the stages that I
make are through the lens of belief this
video is about believe I hope it's it's
my intention I may not always execute on
it as best as I can but it's always my
intention and so if you understand what
your one word is then it allows you to
make your decision making process a lot
cleaner a lot simpler a lot easier next
is your why your purpose comes from your
pain your why comes from your pain the
thing that you want to help and serve
other people with the problem that you
want to solve is the same problem that
you went through the people who you will
love serving are the people who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled with your purpose comes
from your pain and so whatever was the
most painful moment in your life the
moment where you felt the lowest the
worst the the most worthless as a human
being your purpose for the rest of your
life is to help other people who
currently feel that way so think about
who you used to be who you were five
years ago whenever you were struggling
the most there's lots of people who
currently are like you used to be you
want to go serve them and then the how
becomes
how did you get through it how did you
get out of that problem you may not even
be fully out of the problem whatever you
struggled and suffered with you're not
done you're still growing you're still
learning you're still improving you're
still climbing that staircase you know
of knowledge and growth but every time
you take a step up on the staircase you
can reach back and pull somebody else up
one more step one more step The More You
Learn and Grow the more you can pull
people up with you and so however you
got out of the hole even though you're
not done you're better than you used to
be there's lots of people who currently
are who you used to be and so however
you got out becomes a recipe to teach
other people as well and so that's the
first part you're built to serve you go
through the who why how process and you
can figure out with a lot more clarity
the decisions that you need to take in
your life number two is understand that
you want to make big decisions in your
life with your heart and the small ones
with your head big decisions with the
heart small ones with the head don't
make a list people take out a paper and
they make a list of persons don't do
that don't make big decisions logically
because the big things that you want in
life come from creating a new world that
doesn't exist you're you're trying to
create a masterpiece of a life that does
not exist for anybody else your life
will be a masterpiece that nobody has
created yet
that is something that your brain can
understand your brain is logical logic
can't understand creating something new
because that's art that's passion that's
heart your heart can create something
new your brain understands something
that currently exists and so your heart
has to make the big decisions don't make
big decisions through logic you make big
decisions to the things that you love
doing it's why following your passion is
the number one piece of advice
consistently across all high Achievers
successful entrepreneurs innovators
leaders they all say it you have to
follow your passion you have to find a
thing that you love doing
because that's going to carry you to
create something that's never been
created before
and so whenever you're deciding to do
something get your head out of the
equation it's not about logic it's what
do you love doing what do you badly want
to do what would fill you up big
decisions with the heart small ones with
your head so you use your heart to
decide what you want to do and then you
use your head to figure out how to do it
at the very beginning chances are your
head and your heart are against each
other your heart wants to do this and
your head says you can't do that you
didn't go to school you're not capable
of that are you nuts you can't do that
stay here stay safe this is where you
should be your heart says no I want to
do this crazy thing
[Music]
you decide with the heart and then your
head has to come on board when you say I
am doing this
then your brain says okay well she's
serious so let's figure out how to do it
right I'm gonna help use my head now to
figure out how to go off and create this
thing because my heart's demanded it big
decisions with the heart Smalls with the
head and step number three is trust your
ideas and act trust that the ideas that
come to you an idea you probably came to
you today whatever idea flowed through
you trust that it is flowing through you
that it came to you for a reason that
you are a genius that you have great
ideas and that you are not born to sit
here come up with great ideas and do
nothing about them
trust your ideas we don't trust your
ideas enough we don't trust ourselves
enough that idea was given to you for a
reason
you have to go do something about it and
act even though it doesn't make sense
even though people may judge you even
though it's probably not going to work
out the first time you go off and do it
right trust your ideas teach yourself
that as soon as you get an idea that
that's the right thing for you trust
that that's the right thing for you
right now if I'm thinking about
whatever Sushi then Sushi is the right
thing for me I'm going to eat sushi
tonight
it may sound crazy
that's how you need to start making
decisions you need to start listening to
your intuition more right listening to
your heart listen to your gut more
than trying to just follow simple logic
in your head trusted the ideas that come
to you are amazing and that you need to
act on it immediately today right now
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
so one of the things I've been talking
to my audiences about is the
relationship between responsibility and
meaning which is what would you say it's
a it's a constant refrain in the book
it's one of its underlying
um messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
um
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the Baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons but
you need something to put up against
that and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the Instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear conscience is different than
happiness that's better yeah it's better
guilting yourself you're not feeling bad
about yourself that's right you feel
that you've Justified you've Justified
your existence right and so you're not
waking up at three in the morning in a
cold sweat thinking about all the
terrible things that you've involved
yourself in what you said to someone
that you shouldn't have said or how you
acted or what opportunity you lost or or
or or yeah or or the things that you've
that you've let go that you should have
capitalized on and all of that and so if
you think about the times when you're at
peace with yourself with regards to how
you're conducting yourself in the world
it's almost always conditions under
which you've adopted responsibility
right at least the most the most guilt I
think that you can experience perhaps is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and I unless you're Psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
only are you not taking care of yourself
let's say so someone else has to but
you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that if you
concentrate solely on your career you
can get a long way in your career and I
would say that that's a strategy that a
minority of men preferentially do that's
all they do they work like 70 80 hours a
week they go flat out on their career
they're staking everything on the small
probability of exceptional status in a
narrow domain but it's hard on them they
don't have a life it's very difficult
for them to have a family they don't
know how to take any Leisure activity
like they get very one-dimensional now
it may be that that unidimensionality is
the price you have to pay to be
exceptional at one thing right because
if you're going to be something like a
genius level mathematician and you want
to do that for or a scientist say it's
like you're in your lab you're in your
lab all the time you're working 70 hours
a week or 80 hours a week you're smart
you're dedicated you're uni-dimensional
and that's how you get to beat all the
other people who are doing that it's the
only way but the problem is you don't
get a life now if you love being a
scientist and you have that kind of
focus of Mind well first of all you're a
rare person and second you're going to
pay for it but find more power to you
but
but it's a
it's a risky business to do that you
sacrifice a lot for it you know and I
would say most often if you're speaking
about having a healthy life that isn't
what you do you spread yourself out more
so you know you have a family you have
some things that you do outside of work
that are meaningful to you and useful
you you have a network of friends
that that those three things alone are
four things alone or plenty to keep you
well oriented and then if one of those
things collapses
you know everything doesn't go now the
price you pay for that is the more you
strive to optimize that balance the less
likely you are to be fantastically
successful at any single one of them but
you might have a very you know if you
can consider your life as a whole
that might be a winning strategy it's
like make a damn schedule and stick to
it okay so what's the rule with the
schedule it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well I don't like to
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
I have to do this then I have to do this
then I have to do this you know and then
I just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that I have
to do it's like wrong set the damn
schedule up
so that you have the day you want that's
the trick it's like okay I've got
tomorrow if I was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day I could
have
practically speaking what would it look
like well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy so maybe 20
of your day has to be responsibility and
obligation or maybe it's more than that
depending on how far behind you are but
even that you can you can ask yourself
okay well I've got these
responsibilities I have to schedule the
damn things in what's the right ratio of
responsibility to reward and you can ask
yourself that just like you'd negotiate
with someone who is working for you it's
like okay you got to work tomorrow
okay so I want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes I don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know do you have to negotiate with
yourself and not tyrannize yourself like
you're negotiating with someone that you
care for that you would like to be
productive and have a good life and and
that's how you make the schedule it's
like and then you look at the day and
you think well if I had that day that'd
be good great you know and you you're
useless and horrible so you'll probably
only hit it with about 70 percent
accuracy but that beats the hell out of
zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for God's sake or because you're you're
going to hit that position where things
start to loop back positively and spiral
you upward and so
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness is a plan a life
you'd like to have and and you do that
partly by referring to social norms
that's more or less rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale but the way
other way you do that is by having a
little conversation with yourself about
as if you don't really know who you are
because you know what you like you won't
do what you're told you won't do what
you tell yourself to do you must have
noticed that it's like you're a bad
employee and a worse boss and both of
those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but but you know
my point is is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant so to speak you're someone that
you have to negotiate with you don't
have to necessarily have done anything
wrong for things to get completely out
of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a mode of being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there well too as far as I'm concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying watching things on YouTube that
not only do you not want to watch that
you don't even care about that make you
feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know what you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt take a bit of a look at
yourself and think about what's not so
good that you could improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve you
know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at your University or maybe you're
maybe you're at work and you've got this
stack of paper there you know and you
haven't looked at that damn stack for
like a month and you know that you
should be and you're bothering yourself
at night because you're avoiding that
it's like maybe think I've avoided that
stack of paper completely for one month
I'm quite a coward when it comes to
whatever snakes might be hidden in that
stack of paper
how about tomorrow I just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and I like I glanced through it for
15 seconds see if I can do that
it's like well
you set yourself a goal of improvement
you know it's a humble goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is 15 seconds
of exposure to a stack of paper you know
it could easily be you've been avoiding
it you're obviously afraid of it and so
the situation could be that dismal and
dire and you might think well geez it's
no
bombed my ego it's no
it's it's no it's not fostering the
strength of my ego to recognize myself
someone who could only withstand 15
seconds of exposure to that thing I'm
afraid of and so that's a form of
humility too it's like
there's things you can do to improve and
you know what they are and there's small
steps that you could take that you might
take that would put you in that
direction and then the question is are
you big enough to take those small steps
you know are you capable of grappling
with the fact that you're fundamentally
flawed to the point where you have to
break things down into almost childlike
steps in order to manage them and the
answer to that is yeah you are and
that's the lot of
I don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so I would
say to some degree it's the lot of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental Improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
I do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that I could do
that would be better and and you tried
and you find out and as you try it and
you find out generally you get better at
it and you can take on larger and larger
challenges I started to pay very careful
attention to what I was saying
I don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but I could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and I've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them after they've listened
to some of the material that that I've
been describing to all of you but
split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot and that
like to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was watching
that part like just with its eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about
that isn't true and I thought that's
really interesting so now I've and that
was happening to like 95 of what I was
saying and so then I didn't really know
what to do I thought okay this is
strange so maybe I've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all I
mean it wasn't like I was hearing voices
or anything like that I mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people have multiple
parts
so then I had a this weird conundrum it
was like well which of these two things
are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's rubbish that's a lie
that's you're doing that to impress
people you're just trying to win the
argument you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and I didn't know but I decided I would
go with the critic and then what I tried
to do what I learned to do I think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that I mean I'm still trying to
do that because I'm always feeling when
I talk whether or not the words that I'm
saying are either making me align or
making me come apart
and I think the alignment I really do
think the alignment is I think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because I think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but I
believe that you can feel that and I
learned some of that from Reading Carl
Rogers by the way who's a great
clinician because he talked about mental
health in part as a coherence between
the the the the spiritual or the or the
abstract and the physical that the two
things were aligned and and there's a
lot of idea of alignment in in
psychoanalytic and clinical thinking
but anyways I decided that I would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
I had to stop saying almost everything
that I was saying I would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and and
I mean this was over a few months but
it's a hell of a shark to wake up and
realize that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock you know and you might
think well do you really want all of
that to burn off it's like well there's
nothing left but a little husk five
percent of you it's like well if that
five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen you have to negotiate
until you come to the best solution that
can be negotiated which isn't
necessarily a perfect solution but it
might be the best one that can be done
and then you have to stick with it until
the next negotiation and if you get
upset during the negotiations which you
likely will because these are difficult
topics how to divide up responsibilities
in the house and people get mad because
they feel they've been taken advantage
of or aren't being listened to one of
the rules was well you can leave the
discussion but only until you calm down
and then you have to come back because
these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people do them
resentfully because they're sort of
forced by their own orderliness or their
own conscientiousness or or
We Know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through you can tell if you've got the
balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as the
people are still in the conversation and
communicating then you then you've got
the balance right you know and you might
have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
um maybe sometimes when you're
negotiating something that's difficult
you have to offer that other person the
opportunity to sleep on their decision
too which I think is often a very good
idea if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very useful
to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look I'm interested
in this and it seems good but I'm not
going to agree until I sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision if you sleep on it you have to
be
humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low especially in those places where
you're not functioning well and it might
be so embarrassing that you can't
even that you can't bring yourself to
Fathom that that's actually who you are
but you know Jung described the fool
the archetypal figure of the trickster
And The Fool as the precursor to the
Savior to the Redeemer and that's
unbelievable bit of wisdom because what
you meant was that to put yourself
together which is to follow the path of
redemption
to follow the Redeemer
if the Redeemer is a type of Personality
that you could in fact be inhabited by
or manifest then this first steps
towards that is to allow yourself to be
a fool
right it's because
you you don't know what you're doing you
have to admit that and there's going to
be a loss of ego or destruction of ego
arrogant ego that necessarily
accompanies that but you need the loss
of that arrogant ego because it's
precisely what's interfering with your
movement forward you know it's part of
the adversarial process mythologically
speaking that stops moral progress
you're too proud of who you think you
are to notice what you're like so that
you could change properly you don't want
to sacrifice that part of yourself it's
probably associated with some delusion
that helps you maintain in uh
what would you say a positive although
very fragile self-image you know in the
absence of genuine effort if you're
harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless you're like a
rabbit
a rabbit isn't virtuous it's just it
just can't do anything except get eaten
it's not virtuous
if you're a monster and you don't act
monstrously then you're virtuous but you
also have to be a monster well you see
this all the time Harry Potter's like
that too it's like he's he's flawed he's
hurt he's got evil in him he can talk to
snakes man he breaks rules all the time
all the time he's not obedient at all
but you know he has a good reason for
breaking the rules and it if he couldn't
break the rules him and his little
Clique of rule-breaking you know
troublemakers if they didn't break the
rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal
so it's very peculiar but it's it's very
very it's a very very very very very
common mythological notion you know the
hero has to be
the hero has to be a monster
but a controlled monster Batman is like
that you know I mean it's it's
everywhere it's it's the story you
always hear stop doing the things that
you know are wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's it's a fairly it's a
fairly limited attempt first of all
we're not going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or another you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
going to be doubtful about you're not
going to know which way is up and which
way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do now some
of those you won't stop doing for
whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now
but there's another subset that you
could stop doing it might be little
thing well that's fine stop doing it and
see what happens and what will happen is
your vision will clear a little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of apprehension that you will
also know you should stop doing and that
you could stop doing because you
strengthened yourself a bit by stopping
doing the particular stupid thing that
you were doing before that just puts you
together a little bit more and you can
do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and you know that doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to
ever be able to formulate a clear and
final picture of what constitutes the
truth and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's bad
and you know that's not a bad start when
I was 25 or so I probably weighed about
138 pounds I smoked like a pack of
cigarettes a day I drank
tremendous amount of alcohol I was from
Northern Alberta this rough little town
up in Northern Alberta called Fairview
and you know there were long Winters
there and my friends were heavy Drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on oil rigs and you know it was
a rough town and we drank a lot I
started when I was 14 and you know um
and so I was I had a lot of bad habits
let's say and uh things that were and I
wasn't in great shape physically and I
was also still intellectually obsessed
by as I am now and uh so that would have
been that would have been in 85 but when
I but I decided around that about 85 84
something like that maybe a little
earlier that I was really going to try
to get my act together and uh
so I started doing that I you know I
first of all I I quit smoking Well that
took a long time because I eventually
had to quit drinking too in order to
quit smoking and I started working out
starting playing sports which I'd never
done you know I don't regret that I had
a fine time when I was a kid and but uh
I needed really to get disciplined and I
had to do it because
I was working on these hard problems
that you know that I've been discussing
with all of you and I've been working on
them really you know obsessively since I
was probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point around 25
when I was in graduate school trying to
get my phds doing all my research like I
published 15 papers by the time I
graduated with my PhD which was by I
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any graduate student at that
time had ever published at McGill I
think that's right might have been twice
as many or maybe twice as many maybe
even three times as many and at the same
time I wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible terribly difficult
thing to do because I was writing about
three hours a day doing that and I
couldn't do all that and continue with
my misbehavior you know my sort of my
what what would you say my my my
hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that I just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
I had to stop that's the sacrifice I had
to stop you're actually tougher than you
think you never knew that and maybe you
didn't want to take on the
responsibility because you know people
play a role in their own demise so to
speak when you had opportunity to go out
and explore or withdraw because you were
afraid you chose to withdraw because you
were afraid so it's not only that you
were overprotected often it's that you
were willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were overprotected and run
back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind I
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the great father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself so
then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40. so then you take people
out
you say well what are you afraid of rank
it from one to ten
so 10 is make a list of 10 things you're
afraid of the least the thing you're
least afraid of we'll call number ten so
we'll start with that okay well I'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine being in an
elevator let's go out to an elevator and
let you watch the terrible jaws of death
open because that's how you're
responding to it symbolically right and
you're going to do that at it at the the
closest
proximity you can manage you find out
you go do that it works you're nervous
as hell especially from an anticipatory
perspective shaking you go out you stop
you watch it happen and you actually
calm down you do that 10 times and it no
longer bothers you well what you've
learned that you didn't die but more
importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned and then you move a little
closer and then you move a little closer
and then you move a little closer and
finally you're back in what's no longer
the elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
hmm turns out I can withstand that and
then you're met much more together much
more confident and that's often one of
the things that often happens in
situations like that I've seen this
multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often start
standing up to people around them in a
way they never did before you need a
value hierarchy it's inevitable that you
have a value hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top I would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that each
person is of divine value and that the
most appropriate way of interacting with
potential is by embodying and speaking
the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be at
the highest Pinnacle of the value
structure I would say that's what the
logos is
and so
the soul is a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different Pathways in in
the choice between different ways of
transforming the potential of the future
into the actuality of the present and it
does that
by making ethical Decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into the being of
the present that is good and to the
degree that it does that in a manner
that's evil and contaminated by
malevolence and hatred and vengefulness
then it takes a pathway that corrupts
the world and makes things worse and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also that active part of the Soul
that's shaping the deeper soul in some
sense which would be something like the
cumulative consequence of all those
choices something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character it was the night before we
were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping you know and I
was going to test the joints these are
supposed to be glued together with this
pipe glue right and I said I told him I
had to test the joints and he said well
you don't have to test my joints they
never leak and I thought yeah that's
okay how about if I test them so I went
up on the third floor and filled the
pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to and
like half an hour later I had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so well so he wasn't particularly
competent that's the point of that story
but even more so he had put a bunch of
the plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so I
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
Joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a Tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a trades person it's a bloody
reliable honorable uh forthright
productive way of making a living and
there is a hell of a lot of difference
between a working man who knows what
he's doing and one who doesn't both in
terms of skill and ethics right and you
work with someone who knows what they're
doing it's a bloody pleasure they tell
you what they're going to do they tell
you how much it will cost they go and do
it it works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they
failed to recognize completely that
there are differences in rank between
people it's not such a terrible thing
man maybe you wouldn't be a great lawyer
like it's certainly possible most people
aren't but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one go try in another
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top you know flap about
uselessly and whine about your life it's
not helpful it'll just make you
miserable you're not reliable to anyone
you can't help out in a crisis it's like
so you tell young people and this is
another message for conservatives like I
don't care what you're going to do but
go out there and make something of
yourself for God's sake be an honest
person and work and get to the top of
whatever it is that you want to get to
the top of you know and and and and
stand up for yourself like a respectable
human being and be a bit of a light on
the world instead of a blight you know
and you can tell young people people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody World beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life or life worth living it's like yeah
it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the damn universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that I went to Harvard a month
ago month and a half I used to teach
there and I talked to a bunch of
students you know and I told them it's
not easy to get into Harvard you know
like you're a valedictorian if you're at
Harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's I
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me not
everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am I saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids so I told them what I just told you
it's like here you are at Harvard it's
like get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something get the hell out
there and make the world that put you
here happy that you were put there in
that great institution you know and they
came up to me afterwards and said God I
wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year it's like
Jesus why didn't someone tell them that
for God's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest University in the world is it
so difficult to figure that out we're
built for struggle us human beings not
after
the bubbles of bliss that Dostoevsky
described in in Notes from Underground
were built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and Fortune might do
you win but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do it isn't merely that
your fate depends on whether or not you
get your act together and to what degree
you decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to Peak
at about 9 billion by the way and then
it'll decline rapidly but seven billion
people in the world and who are you
you're just one little dust moat among
that seven billion and so it really
doesn't matter what you do or don't do
but that's simply not the case it's the
wrong model because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media you'll you'll know
a thousand people at least over the
course of your life and they'll know a
thousand people each and that puts you
one person away from a million and two
persons away from a billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffered dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless suffering
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the Martyr so that's a pretty good deal
All Things Considered especially when
they are when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century now
this the baboon here who's supposed to
be basically just a fool when the story
was first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it's represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than than that too
because we know that if you take
yourself and you put yourself in a new
environment new genes turn on in your
nervous system they encode for new
proteins and so you're full of
biological potential that won't be
realized unless you move yourself around
in the world into different challenging
circumstances and that'll turn on
different circuits so it's not merely
that you're incorporating information
from the outside world in the
constructivist sense it's that by
exposing yourself to different
environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
Central and that would be say like The
Rock in The Pride Rock in The Lion King
because you take yourself out of your
Dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have Adventure and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too you don't tell your kid here is an
impossible thing why don't you go out
and fail you say here's something worth
going after here's a step you could take
that would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
called that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a Russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
Zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone you're expanding
your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay I need to set a
goal but I need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it right and then you go
then you've got it perfectly because
it's not so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well I could do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well I
set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why I'm being a victim yeah which
isn't helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem but but there
are certainly proper ways of dealing
with it if you configure your life
so that what you are genuinely doing is
aiming at the highest possible good
than the things that you need to
to survive
and to thrive on a day-to-day basis will
deliver themselves to you
that's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis right because it what
it basically says is if you dare to do
the most difficult thing that you can
conceptualize your life will work out
better than it will if you do anything
else
well how are you going to find out if
that's true well it's a character
Guardian leap of faith there's no way
you're going to find out whether or not
that's true unless you do it so no one
no one can tell you either because
just because it works for someone else I
mean that's interesting and all that but
it's no proof that it'll work for you
you have to be all in in this game there
is no more effective way of operating in
the world than to conceptualize the
highest good that you can and then
strive to attain it there's no
more practical Pathway to the kind of
success that you could have if you
actually knew what success was you'll
discover a little bit more about your
potential as you discover who you are
especially the darker parts of yourself
because then you discover your potential
for Mayhem there's some real utility in
that you know a discovery that you're
dangerous it's such a useful discovery
it's actually something that strengthens
you because the first thing
that a realization like that can in fact
produce is the
the ambition to incorporate that danger
into a higher order personality that
dangerousness into a higher order
personality and that can make you
implacable
I can make you someone who can say no
when you need to say no you know that
can make you someone who won't avoid
necessary conflict and so that's as
unbelievably useful the world shifts
itself around your aim because you're
you're a creature that has a name you
have to have a name in order to do
something you're an Aiming creature you
look at a point and you move towards it
it's built right into you and so you
have a name well let's say your aim is
the highest possible aim
well then so that sets up the world
around you it organizes all of your
perceptions it organizes what you see
and you don't see it organizes your
emotions and your motivations
so you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is the day
manifests itself as a set of challenges
and problems and if you solve them
properly then you stay on the pathway
towards that ain't and you can
concentrate on the on the on the day and
so that way you get to have your cake
and eat it too because you can you can
point into the distance the far distance
and you can live in the day
and it seems to me that that's
that makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
how because if everything that you're
doing every day is related to the
highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize well that's the very
definition of the meaning that would
sustain you in your life you want to
know how to structure your life properly
according to Jordan Peterson check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there